hey it's Tim Dylan and fear not we are
on the porch we have a live video for
you but if you want an actual episode
every week and if you want all the two
years of audio archives to the show and
if you want longer versions of those
videos you put out on Twitter and
Instagram and if you want to help
suggest things that we talked about on
the show you want to interact with us
patreon.com slash the Tim Dylan show
this is a great way to support the show
and contribute to it thank you
[Music]
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me thank you for
considering your fellow patrons welcome
to the Tim Dylan show everybody we are
here on the porch this is I don't know
when this is gonna this is coming out
obviously next Sunday this Sunday
whatever it is Thursday night Megan
McCain had a diatribe about gun buyback
program that's being proposed she said
there's gonna be a lot of violence which
is probably correct but she said it in
typical Megan McCain fashion which no
matter what she said you would want to
hate her and you wouldn't be wrong
because the thing about Megan and I know
people that know her and in real life
they have confided in me that she is a
monster um she's a real rich chick in
every sense of the word she's got a job
that she did not earn her knowledge base
on world issues is non-existent on
domestic issues same but she pops off
she's my aunt
she's my aunt with a national platform
she's my aunt but given millions and
millions of dollars
to spew whatever rolls off her tongue
which it is what it is I mean I know
they're not hiring me on the view they
need a conservative on the view
I'm cooled all that but Meghan McCain
you know she's a legacy of a guy that
conservatives only liked when he was
dead they didn't like him when he was
alive as soon as he said half of my
brain has been eaten they were like oh
he's a hero we love him but up until
then they didn't give a [ __ ] about him
so we did a little video today
mocking Meghan this is you know the
first video that we did since the
original Meghan McCain video and you
know I went to Lane Bryant I got you
know got the white blazer look good
31 bucks what do you fat [ __ ]
complaining about
I got a Rochester big and tall I spent a
hundred and fifty dollars for a [ __ ]
t-shirt 34 bucks you get a beautiful
white blazer you don't know how good you
[ __ ] have it there is nothing for
plus-size men you got to wear a suit or
a Hawaiian shirt or some stupid like ed
hardy you know that's a type of fact
there's two types of fat guy insanely
successful dj khaled or quasi homeless
bum who lives with his brother those are
the two types of fat guy that exists in
the minds of people that make clothing
and I remembered I've known both of
those fat guys I knew a lawyer who was
like 450 tailored suits custom when I
was selling mortgages he'd walk in he
always looked great he was a fat well
but he was tailored everything fit
pinstripe suits three-piece walking the
guy looked gray and I knew my friends
uncle who was just a fat mass who would
like crash high school party
he was like 40 got in the limo with us
wants you're going to a strip club
somebody got like a shitty limo and he
got in the limo with us and he was
talking all the way to the strip club
about how he's gonna lose goals suitors
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] and I think by
the time we got to the strip club he was
asleep I think I'm remembering that word
literally he was asleep by the time we
got to the shrimp Club just like and we
peeler the way come up to like hey man
you want to go in remember that [ __ ]
you were talking about you know you had
to wake him up he was asleep I remember
one of my friends looked to me went
that's sad sad stuff out there that's
why I'm trying to you know I'm trying to
rein it in I don't want to be that guy
trying to press all the young guys and
then falls asleep that's not a cool guy
that's not the guy you want to be but
you know those are the two types of fat
guys out there but fat women you guys
are doing [ __ ] great you got Liz oh
you got popular culture you got it all
you got Lane Bryant by the way how great
were the sales women in Lane Bryant
wonderful wonderful
I'm trying stuff on there fitting me it
doesn't matter that I'm clearly a man in
a woman's store it's 2019 we're in LA
they're like do you need shoes deal with
it and I put makeup on my face cheap
makeup from Target it's made out of acid
cheap makeup cheap lip gloss garbage I
put all this on my skin's falling off of
my face I'm trying to scrub this out of
my pores when I'm done making this video
hair fake eyelashes 30,000 views on
Twitter
nothing 30,000 views I'm essentially
trans
for the video 30,000 [ __ ] views
thanks a lot
very few blue checkmarks all these
people who tweet about mega mccain's the
devil every day and then they don't
retweet this I don't know why maybe it's
too vulgar you're the [ __ ] that are
always liked Eric the gloves off the
gloves are off I'm saying she puts guns
in her [ __ ] and you're not retweeting
it what else would you like me to do and
it's funny I'm not making political
points I don't give a [ __ ] I think it's
hilarious that she's defending guns by
saying that the ak-47 is like the most
popular like it's the prom king I think
that's just funny whether you agree with
gun control I don't care what you think
or believe so don't contact me through
any form of social media and tell me
weirdly none of it go away
I did the nine rants about Europe your
opinion is superfluous it's an
afterthought your your rationale is an
afterthought so don't get it it's funny
it was funny to me when she does those
things and says those things they are
funny I'm a pro-gun guy to an extent but
how many massacres would get you to
alter your position it's a fair question
how many mass shootings would want to
date would one a day get you to just
just look at it again just revise I
don't know maybe not there seems to be
hardcore people out there don't care and
maybe it won't work they'd be banning
the assault weapons maybe it won't work
but how many shootings would make you
try how many what would you need what
what would do it we have so many as the
great Eddie Pepitone said in his special
he's bored by them
they're boring he was right Eddie's
right they don't even matter anymore
no one cares 17 month-old shot in the
face next no one cares
because people think that if we give up
the weapons the government will start to
get too radical start they'll start what
do you think the government would do if
we didn't have the weapons let's think
of it let's brainstorm do you think
potentially the government might start
spying on everybody listening to their
phone calls and reading their emails do
you think possibly the government might
totally suspend habeas corpus and say
that they could decide that you were an
enemy combatant and lock you up in
prison and not charge you with a crime
and keep you there indefinitely and
torture you do you think the government
would start doing that you think the
government would start taking
whistleblowers and locking them with
little boxes and making them go insane
when they've said things like the
military is slaughtering civilians and
the NSA is acting without congressional
authority to just wiretap everybody you
think the CIA might start spying on the
Senate Intelligence Committee and
destroying tapes of their interrogation
which many people and experts have said
is tantamount to torture do you think
the elites would start engaging in
illicit sexual behavior like pedophilia
on private islands and that if that ever
came to light they might potentially
murder the person who was about to
testify even though he was in a
maximum-security prison in New York City
do you think they would get us into
endless wars without any explanation do
you think they would murder journalists
do you think they would do all those
things if we gave up the guns because we
got an arsenal of guns and everything
that I just mentioned is [ __ ]
business is [ __ ] usual so what is the
fear they would just start locking
people up right and left and camp maybe
they would I'm
that thought process I think that's a
little too messy for them do you need to
lock anyone up in camp what is that does
that does the putt but people need to go
to work right so you know people think
or people have it in their head that
we're like this country made up of
freedom fighters who don't take no [ __ ]
we're we're freedom fighters we demand
accountability and if you take our
weapons away it's gonna get real bad cuz
we're not shooting it squirrels in our
backyard we're demanding accountability
with those weapons are we if that was
the case it'd be ten thousand people
right now like you're on Hong Kong where
are the street protests we you have the
weapons you have the guns you have the
you have access to transportation the
people in Hong Kong they don't even have
guns they're getting taken tasers to the
face to show that they're pissed we've
had none of that except a couple of
theater kids fighting a couple of guys
you can't get laid in Portland that's
the only skirmish we've had we got a
couple of vigilantes doing some version
of West Side Story in Portland and
people act like well if they turn to
guns it's gonna be trouble they're gonna
start stepping on our necks huh
I mean I could be wrong I'm willing to
be wrong here I'm willing to engage me
live friends or to libertarians which is
a which is done it's a dumb thing to be
private roads private it's destroy the
government we're gonna live in a turkey
we live in chaos those are always people
who've lived with their mother for too
long those roads people would last about
three minutes in a street fight that
believe those things get rid of
everything chaos and anarchy there's a
tent tent when you're on the when you're
in that side of spectrum or you're a
radical
left us you know your ideas will never
get put into practice so it's easy to
get very romantic about them does it
matter
it's like picture and [ __ ] somebody's
really hot and you know damn well you're
never gonna do it and if you had the
chance to do it you're gonna be nervous
you can barely get hard you know you're
coming in five seconds it's not what you
think it's gonna be but it doesn't
matter cuz you're not Jessica Alba's not
[ __ ] goo so you don't get to play out
that fantasy and make it into a reality
and realize oh I I should [ __ ] her good
right I should make this fun for her
your your ideas our ideas
none of them ever I took the
Libertarians who I like is people like
yeah we should just have private that's
all happening already there are gated
communities there are private roads when
that thing in Malibu happened there were
private firefighters rich people go to
prison they go to private all of the
schools they go to a private all that
[ __ ] is going down already
how much more private [ __ ] do you want
there's every [ __ ] five minutes in
California you run up against the gate
because people are like no this is not
for you not for you this Beach isn't for
you for someone else there's a lot of
private stuff but I don't know if
everyone was walking around with an
ar-15 is the country better off I don't
know I used to believe but no one really
is interested in freedom no one really
cares unless it's about a gun I've had
people say to me Oh curly do read my
email I'm not doing nothing it's not the
point the point is you shouldn't have to
be a child pornographer to care if the
government is reading everything you do
it's not the point well I'm not doing
anything so parents what they're do
because you don't know what's gonna
happen you don't know who's going to be
reading that you don't know what they're
gonna perceive as antisocial behavior
you don't know what you could
potentially say to somebody well I think
the government's doing a bad job
you don't know think of the politicians
really hate whether it's the Clintons
whether it's Trump whoever it is you
hand these people absolute power in
every [ __ ] area of your life you
don't give a [ __ ] you don't care and I
try to tell people I'm like well it's
not good that they have this kind of
power well they're just detained and
Muslims they're just a tiny and
terrorists and anime combines what
what's the criteria for that if we go
into your country we start dropping
bombs on it and you don't and you ain't
pleased you're an enemy combatant if you
don't walk out of your house and go
thank you
thanks for the drone strikes thanks for
the bombs if you don't dance in the
street you're an enemy combatant and we
should just be able to torture you I I
don't is what the FBI does I just read
an article the other day the pen sent me
and I've known this the FBI like gives
guns to mentally [ __ ] Muslims and
and they walk into a mosque and they
pick some kid some like young guy who's
completely unaware that he's even a
human being on earth he doesn't know
what the [ __ ] going on and they hand
him a bomb and then they go he's a
terrorist and then they put him in jail
and they go you better inform we're
gonna torture the [ __ ] out of you mm-hmm
what do you think they deal with the
Boston bombing what do you think we ever
heard about that you ever hear that
trial by the way you think the media is
above the media couldn't cover that
trial cuz they had s am's put on
everyone involved called special
administrative measures put on everyone
involved in that trial you don't think
the media would have been in there you
think the media didn't like it because
Americans got killed you don't think to
mean it you don't think it was salacious
a young kid decent-looking they put him
on the front of Rolling Stone is like
the first [ __ ] hot
vine star terrorist this [ __ ] young
vine star like they call them like the
sexy terrorist that was a
direction they were going in they were
gonna make them you know into that you
don't think they wanted to be in there
with cameras in his [ __ ] face
interviewing him all the time they
weren't allowed to do that
you didn't hear much about that you
didn't hear much about their friend who
the FBI interviewed and killed during
the interview killed him during the
interview we all swallow that but if if
they took our guns away the government
would really start to overreach
government would just start framing
people and killing witnesses it's
they're doing it they're doing it now
I I don't I get it I'm not going after
your gun don't I have friends with guns
guns are fun to shoot I get it people go
hunting I'm not but this whole argument
that you're resilient that you're there
are 1776 militiamen resisting this
tyrannical government because you have a
gun doesn't seem to be borne out by the
facts it's gotten pretty bad at what
point will we start to resist when will
the resisting start and don't take this
the wrong way don't clip doesn't get me
off social media don't get don't get me
taken down but you know what I mean well
when will you start with it when they do
it to you when they walk in your house
they snatch you hmm
yeah but you know nobody wants to talk
about this everybody wants to watch The
Bachelor I get it the fun show who's he
gonna pick who's he gonna choose what
gold-digging [ __ ] will this empty suit
choose who probably doesn't have any
[ __ ] money anyway well everybody if
you notice that I'm wearing the new NYPD
shirt it's from a sketch that we did
where I played Jeffrey Epstein security
guards so they're supporting the police
state with his clothing yeah that's what
I'm doing that's what I'm doing you know
what folks we've had a lot of
discussions here about how to enrich
your life both professionally and
personally and that's something that I'm
really proud of
one of the things that I've told you
[ __ ] people over and over again at
nauseam to the point where I'm banging
my head against the [ __ ] wall and I'm
bleeding is that you need to have a
website no matter what you are doing in
life even if you're an anonymous human
being with no aspirations you don't care
about business and you're living on a
fixed income in a trailer in Oklahoma
still get a website and tell people
about that people need to hear from you
they need to know where you are
and you can't be too saucy on social
they'll [ __ ] splash you right out
they'll take you right out they'll do
platform you you know gotta be a little
careful but not on your own website you
can say whatever you want you can harass
anyone you want on your own website tell
everybody about the Rothschilds who can
stop you it's your own website okay
or you know promote your nail salon I'm
not telling you what to do either or
talk about reptilians that live in the
center of the earth or promote your
wedding photo business or both I would
gladly sign on with a wedding
photographer we talked about
interdimensional reptiles I'd be into
that that's not gonna be everybody she's
gonna be me wix.com it's a better way to
build websites for your clients a lot of
you people can't afford a website to be
done for you you people are in the in
the infancy of your business you don't
know anything you're not a big big dog
you're a little pup just trying to get
some attention just a dog trying to get
a bone just a squirrel trying to get a
not just a raccoon trying to steal some
trash out of the dumpster behind the
local pizzeria that's what you are but
you don't have to always be that one day
you'll be the king of the jungle
feasting on a gazelle in front of a
majestic landscape in Tanzania but not
right now right now you're a field cat
feral whatever shut up okay start with a
blank page design the layout if you want
grow their business with custom online
store out-of-the-box booking system live
chat publish in a click and make edits
fast your clients will enjoy
enterprise-grade security and automatic
web hosting use leading industry SEO
which means your google search terms
will pop up it'll drive people to your
website and therefore to your business
it's a powerful marketing tool you need
to drive traffic to your site and Wix
helps you do that get started on your
next client website today go to wix.com
/gt h1 wix.com /gt h1 okay
that's we got a deal I'm gonna get a
good deal people gonna respect you
you're gonna win you can't afford to lay
out a lot of money upfront you just got
a little bit of an inheritance mommy
just kicked the bucket or maybe your
great-aunt who always smelled weird but
now she's where she belongs in the
ground and you've got thirty six hundred
dollars worth of bond sitting in your
bank account and you need to stretch it
and make it last until you're famous and
rich and everybody loves you and that's
gonna happen but it starts with a
website otherwise you're gonna be
anonymous drinking at some bar talking
about what you could have been what you
should have done be one of those guys
you don't want to be that be a Titan be
a Titan folks Wix wix.com I love it I
use it my family uses it my mother is a
paranoid schizophrenic love lives in a
mental institution has an amazing
website
she just fires off those synapses in her
brain start going she decides publishing
links they don't go nowhere
she's got an online store but you know
beanie babies staying with ranch
dressing that she's willing to sell you
tags have been chewed up like dogs and
cats but listen if she can if she can
make it work so can you you know what I
mean Wix calm /g th1 Wix calm /g th1 do
it you know
listen there was this guy my mother
rented her house out in eighth grade and
I've told told a lot of these stories
I'm not gonna go back into them but
suffice to say she rented it out to a
lot of people who ended up selling drugs
because in Long Island when you were
renting a room and you didn't have any
credit you worked in construction and
construction meant that you sold drugs
and then you also maybe you did
construction but you also sold drugs
that was what it meant and she rented
out to one guy named Dennis Dennis was
the only one in the house not selling
drugs he barely had any [ __ ] money
and he was an older guy he's an
interesting guy he was he's very
spiteful he had a he went to Vietnam he
served in Vietnam came back from Vietnam
how did this thriving baseball card
business him and his wife and the
parties coke booze you know the whole
thing the whole nine or the whole eight
you know coke him his wife got divorced
I don't know why maybe he bought
somebody else I don't know
irreconcilable differences whatever and
instead of giving her alimony he decided
to quit his job and go live in a van
down by the beach by Long Beach okay he
then moved into my mother's house where
he befriended me in my friend Shaye and
he would tell us all these stories about
you know bar fights and Vietnam and he
was a cynic cuz he he was old enough to
have heard all the [ __ ] from every
politician and he ended as many people
do in a room drinking wine out of a
burger can come with ice in it
smoking a pack of Marlboro Reds day and
sang the n-word
now that's neither here nor there and I
don't endorse that kind of behavior I'm
saying
idealism idealism ends usually there is
what I'm saying if you don't have a
healthy dose of cynicism you're gonna
end up like Dennis Dennis was not a bad
man he wasn't great
he's kids hadn't spoken with five years
they called him once and he was so drunk
he answer you are huh huh and they went
hi dad new hair all done and they said I
think I'm gonna go and go whatever after
everything that happened Dennis said
life in the big city it was one of my
favorite quotes he ever said life in the
big city my mother would go the cops are
gonna probably raid the house cuz
they're running a pretty big coke
operation upstairs and Dennis would go
life in the big city my mother would go
your kids you haven't seen in five years
called you and because you were so drunk
they hung up the phone and they never
want to speak to you again life in the
big city it would say that he'd sit
there holding his hunting knife in a
chair staring at the fire drinking cheap
wine out of a Burger King big cop with
ice in it smoking Marlboro Reds and
saying life in the big city he had a few
other sayings now these are not good
sayings I do not speak this way and I
could say it was a different time but
there was no time when this was
appropriate you'd walk around and say
there's an n-word in the woodpile I
don't know what that meant I don't know
why he would say that he was he was a
deranged man who had lost most of what
you could ever get in life he had
nothing left he's dead you can't cancel
him you can't cancel Dennis he died
exactly as he should have clutching his
chest on a fishing boat in front of his
brother he wasn't young he was in his
late 50s or early 60s probably early 60s
had he had one last you know he loved
playing cards and I don't
endorse the sayings but life in the big
city I don't think that was the worst
way to handle everything and Dennis had
guns Dennis had a lot of guns under his
bed in the closet but Dennis had those
guns in case somebody came into the
house he shoots him in the face so he
said if he was sober enough to find a
gun get his finger on the trigger and
god that was never tested would have
shot me shot me when I was just trying
to do a line in the bathroom like an
eighth grader getting ready for school
but life in the big city is kind of
where you end up in many cases we'd sit
there with my mother that he baked clams
they'd eat linguine with red clam sauce
he would smoke cigarettes while he ate
no one does that anymore
you loved beer you loved wine no hard
stuff he swore most of that off and he
was a good guy I remember my
grandmother's funeral he was after my
mother's house was lost
Dennis moved into my mother's van he
came full circle moved into my mother's
van and then he parked it in my
grandmother's driveway and he would
shower in my grandmother's house and he
would live in the van and he would give
me advice you give my mother advice
living in a van in a driveway in Long
Island he would say this is what you got
to do and this is how you got to do it
this is how you must proceed this is the
way life is sometimes you'd kind of say
to him and he'd say hey I'm living in a
van in the driveway life in the big city
I never lived in a big city
no never lived in a big city no I've
been to the city a handful of times but
the city was not part of his existence
it was very comfortable on the marsh of
Long Island I remember he came to my
grandmother's funeral he moved in with
another man in New York another man in
my town and now this man had a son and
this man's son would get
got out of jail every three years and
try to kill his father this is a fact
get out of jail every three years go try
to kill his father and also try to kill
Dennis you know they'd have to jam the
door shut and everything every black
clockwork Dennis would come over the
house and go Joey's out tried to kill us
again and we go yeah well that's it's
that time uh you know Dennis came to my
grandmother's funeral you guys I just
got a brand-new gun I said oh good and
he goes and I'll tell you right now
because when Joey gets out this time
when I see him I'm just gonna kill him
before even has a chance to make it onto
the lawn when I see him I'm gonna kill
him this is what people are using guns
for they're not using it to form a power
paramilitary force to check your well
Ian's overreach of government not that
I've seen they're using it for these
types of skirmishes and and not that
it's completely unnecessary
but let's not delude ourselves
Dennis was not railing against the state
he just wanted to shoot his friend's son
before his friend's son came in the
house and tried to kill his father and
Dennis that's all I get it you know life
in the big city
I miss Dennis that it was again not not
winning any awards as a humanitarian
who's not the most woke person I think
we've established that he was not woke
he was barely awake literally you know
but that's what it is and I'm not saying
that's the only reason people use guns
people use guns for a lot of reasons and
some of them are good some of them make
a lot of sense but what people are also
using
for is to walk into a market or school
and shoot people in the face now you
look at the internet you see the
direction things are moving you see that
mental illness is widespread it's not
being it's not being cared for nobody
is prioritizing their mental health and
wellness other than this fake self-care
horseshit which is you know to get
people to buy candles there is no such
thing as self-care when you work three
jobs a week to feed your baby cat food
eventually you snap okay I don't care
how many baths you run if you're always
one car accident away from bankruptcy
and homelessness it doesn't matter if
you light a lavender candle you're gonna
snap we push people to the brink we push
them to the edge people are competing on
American Ninja Warrior for insulin in
this country and acting like it's a
privilege so they're gonna snap China
does it when you work when they work you
to death at the Apple Factory you try to
kill yourself
Foxconn puts all these tents I'm not
tense annette's so you can't kill
yourself you just land in the net and
they come and I guess pick you up and go
get back online go back to work okay
which is inhumane what if you handed all
those people guns
I bet there'd be some issues I bet there
would be but that's where rat in this
country and I know that people listen to
the show for positive reinforcement and
that's what I give you most of the time
most of the time this show is about
positivity love and light but you know I
tried to talk to somebody the other day
about state of the world yeah if you
read that new article on Zero Hedge
which kind of interesting they got a lot
of [ __ ] on that site but they like
the central bankers
preparing for the collapse of the dollar
by saying let's institute a new
cryptocurrency that serves our needs
better than the dollar rich people are
hoarding cash people are cutting
interest rates there's a lot of doomsday
signs for the economy you try to tell
somebody this and they respond you
complicit man put that [ __ ] out of your
head we're living in Paradise and I
understand I understand why people feel
that way it's because they're insane and
I understand you were rewarded for being
insane in this country for being insane
you were rewarded I'm like half crazy
there's no money in that you got to go
full [ __ ] psychopath full lunatic and
to ignore reality to ignore you know I
brought up I'm like you know people are
living in tents it's not good and one of
my friends goes friend I love good
person talented person they were like
yeah but there's been Hoovervilles
people have always been living at dance
is that the response is that the
response people have always been living
in tents things are fine things are fine
we're not in a tent that's most people's
way to process things ago hey I'm that's
what people handle mass shootings they
go I'm not dead yet hey I ain't dead
soon that'll be a point in the argument
somebody got CNN go well I'm pretty
alive and so are you so maybe you should
relax John and outside the windows will
hear and they'll go well I'm here what's
your big issue
stop being a negative Ned stop being so
negative about these mass shootings am I
the only one who sees these mass
shootings is a great way to appreciate
life it's a great way to appreciate life
to hear about 28 people that got mowed
down at a farmers market makes you feel
warm and fuzzy inside that you're on
your fat ass and you don't have any lead
in you yet I'm still alive I'm not in a
chant this
the thought process things are great
especially in LA go things are great and
if you bring up anything you know have
to I do this I sneak this in now I go I
go out to dinner I go yeah everybody's
good good good what do we get
yeah episode when you get the prawns the
prawns okay 50% of American children
living in poverty what is the sauce with
the prawns what kind of sauce is it is
it it's like a lime sauce right yeah no
half the kids are they don't have food
or medicine what do we want to do for an
entree what do we want to split
something I'm not that hungry
and people don't people don't care like
people are like stop ruining everything
you're doing good so many people in this
country they're one car action in a way
from bankruptcy from financial disaster
they really are
everybody's like they're like Mario you
know you jump over the little thing
do-do-do-do-do-do-do jump over it almost
got sideswipe jump over it almost got
laid off
hey laid off everyone else they laid off
my best friend he's in trouble do dude
get the coin run we're almost done with
the level quick speed speed mushroom job
jump you know I don't have that rare
blood cancer
oof hitting that documentary did jump
fly oh good my aunt left me $2,800 when
she died
good that's that's the that's the having
the raccoon tail I can fly over the
problems for a little while we're living
in a video okay and if you try to bring
people's attention to that they think
you're the you're a lunatic you know I
just want to be in love I want to be in
the type of love literally where I look
in somebody's eyes during a mass
shooting
and we're both being riddled with
bullets and I don't care because I
believe that love is out there that
all-encompassing love I just wanna I
want to be another if I wanted that's
why I'm on keto and I'm gonna lose a
bunch of weight because I want to find
that person out there that no matter
what happens we take a honeymoon to the
Amazon rainforest
then we're like is this beautiful and
all the sudden we see these people
lighting fires and you see people
running out of their houses with their
babies and they're screaming and I go
it's so beautiful here and they're good
yeah man it's just so nice so peaceful
coarse unlucky and the screams now we
don't hear the screams we hear you would
far enough away you just kind of see the
people's mouths gape and you hear
something that sounds like a scream but
it could also be just a beautiful bird
and that's where I want to get to in my
life because that's the way to live you
know we're making these videos that are
satirizing [ __ ] we're trying too hard
we're trying too hard we're gonna start
we're gonna adjust we're gonna have new
videos you're gonna be better and it's
just gonna be me [ __ ] I'm going to
[ __ ] for one minute or maybe 25 seconds
cuz the minutes a little long now for 25
seconds I am going to take a [ __ ] in a
different cookie place okay
and instead of doing that video with the
pink wall I'm just gonna take a [ __ ] and
I'm gonna start flinging it at people
I'm gonna fling my own [ __ ] at people
and I'm hoping that's gonna get the
numbers up I don't know but that's what
I'm gonna try to do I'm going to start
defecating in different fun cooky places
and then taking my own [ __ ] and hurling
it in the air and dancing and
that is the entertainment that you
people out there deserve and that's what
you're gonna get
I just wanna you know somebody just told
me they do an American Ninja Warrior but
it's gonna be in the water it's gonna be
in the water
they got asked to maybe host it it's a
new American ninja war
I want a host I want to host real
competition shows real ones or at the
end of it
we give you kid an insulin shot at the
end of it and people will defend that no
go they're new a dude gets a competition
fair and square
hey do it do it getting into hello I'm
back again
talking about better help which a lot of
people you know believe is a scam I've
had people say that they've had positive
experiences with it so what do you
[ __ ] want from me you know they're
advertising on the program now if it if
it I've told you before if you have a
sexual fetish and you want to call up
better help and masturbate on the line I
have no problem with that okay
better help is an online counseling
service okay it offers licensed
professional counselors who specialize
in issues like depression stress anxiety
relationships sleeping anger family
conflict self-esteem and more it lets
you connect with your professional
counselor at a safe and private online
environment anything you share is contra
this is kind of confident it's
confidential this is controversial
anything you share is controversial
wouldn't it be hilarious I'm having
trouble sleeping what the [ __ ] would you
a Nazi everything you say is
controversial
it's a combative therapist everything
they say everything you can find them
they accuse you being a Nazi you know me
my girlfriend just don't connect the way
we used to is it because you want to
kill Jews Nazi you're like what with
better help you can schedule secure
video or phone sessions Plus chat and
tax with your therapist - it's Tim I'm
having issues
and I need help well welcome to better
help my name is Marlene how's it going
fatty what how's it going Fat Boy why
are you calling me that Marlene I'm a
licensed counselor with better help what
kind of license do you have shut up you
shut your mouth I'm a doctor I'm a
doctor and you respect me
okay well Marlene have bad anxiety
sometimes I get real dizzy and public
places maybe I'm a core a phobic I don't
like going out well then stay in stay in
fat ass Marlene I'm not even that
overweigh oh you're a fat boy I can hear
you
chewing satiating yourself filling
yourself Marlene this sounds sounds
insane I thought you were gonna help me
oh I'm helping your fat ass I'm your
better help counselor then that was
literally that was audio from a better
help call than I did and it's not I
think it's fine I think it's good if you
feel shitty all better how call account
if you feeling down call better help are
the counselor are the counselors
licensed hey shut up you narc just talk
to someone on the phone don't sit in
your apartment all alone
you poor you're fat you gay you're dumb
you got a disease and you can't come
whatever it is
there's better help we employ the best
drifters on the market
I'm kidding they're all great it's all
great they're licensed professionals are
gonna help you they're gonna help you
with your issues are you afraid are you
depressed are you fearful are you
anxious are you sad call better help and
they'll tell you to shut your mouth now
they give you good strategies call me up
I'm better help you yeah yeah say
something
Ave better your mouth oh hey is this
better help I'm filling hey shut up for
a minute
this is better help my name is Frank and
I'm your counselor hey Frank going
through a long-term relationship just
split up with my girl I'm in my own
place does it sound like you're going
through a long-term relationship sounds
like you just ended one well can you go
through a breakup sorry okay Jesus
Christ you see nothing know what's
happening
go on out of it now go on I'm feeling
really depressed that she didn't let me
have any friends so now that we're not
together you know I'm very alone I've no
one that really talked to and that's
honestly why I'm calling you just to
have someone to listen to me hey kid
friend of mine before DNA before DNA I
could tell you how to fix this problem
you know what I mean but they'll get you
now whatever you do so don't do nothing
don't leave don't leave nothing on a
doorstep don't follow her you know just
get some horse did that help
yeah thanks Frank I appreciate it you're
welcome better help don't kill your
chick it's better the help is better
when you call and online let's do one
more
hi hi Stan
hey Kirsten hi hey hi it's kind of a
humbling moment for me I don't usually
reach out for help but you know this is
okay that's what we're here for it's
called better help that's what they said
when they hired Mya
No thank you can legally have to talk to
you know it does your sweetie you're so
sweet I can hear it in your voice you're
sweet oh thanks what's your issue well
I've been having performance issues in
the in the bedroom in the bedroom yeah
like I just can't get it up and I feel
like you know I'm just not really
attracted to my wife anymore I'm
starting to have these thoughts about
like men and I don't know I'm just kind
of confused sexually and it's depressing
me a lot I you know I've dated many men
that were probably gay and I just
started pegging them so your wife needs
to put on a strap-on and [ __ ] you right
would she have a problem with that no I
don't think so she wants to spice it up
it's what she's been saying all along
so it's space it ah okay I've gotten to
the point where I can only come if my
face is being pushed into a garbage
disposal and I hear the garbage being
ground up in the kitchen
I can only calm if I'm being [ __ ]
sideways and my head is being smashed
and I hear that gurgling sound so just
yeah hell yeah thanks Kat thank you
folks it's a great company let's tell
you where they go here
let's tell you how it all works here's
them here's what you do folks I'm dead
serious you need help you don't have
money call these people are you gonna
help
yeah it what the yes the [ __ ] do I know
what's he doing ten percent off what's
that some guy with a flash is just dark
on that trail so you just lie yeah
that's good
you know cocking his gun get ten percent
off your first month by going to better
help calm slashed him Dylan better help
calm slash Tim Dylan okay great let's
see one more
hi my name is my name is Carl
welcome to better help hey Carl how's it
going man listen I'll just cut right to
the chase
I got excommunicated from my church I
got caught with I was a deacon I got
caught with this young girl my entire
community as as as they're not talking
to him anymore I can't get through to
anybody
very very alone I feel very isolated I'm
starting to have violent thoughts I'll
be honest I've always had violent
thoughts but now they're starting to
really increase kid could you help me
out I mean do I need to get on
medication do I need I need just to call
you once a week what is your
relationship with a girl right now uh
well I mean the family locked her up in
her in her bedroom from what I
understand there's actual relations with
her yeah we did have you filmed it no no
I didn't you have any audio or
photographs that could help me better
understand the nature of your sexual
relationship no I'm really sorry man I
can't even if I had I couldn't send that
to you it's you know it's I mean she's a
minor I'm going to court for this you
want to hold do you want help
yes in order for me to give you the best
help that I need I need to see exactly
what happened or hear about it in great
detail okay I need to see it and
understand it and when I see
when I feel it do you understand that
yes yes okay yes I scratch your back you
scratch mine you know what I mean it's
called better help we all need help
you're not the only one that on this
called heads out I need some help okay
you have that her address let's get her
out
let's spring her better help slash Tim
Dylan thanks no yeah it's not that bad
gets good things happen and there's
great things happening it's great things
that it's fine there's beautiful stairs
nice stuff there's nice hotels and ice
and you can live in an igloo
that dumb glass thing that [ __ ] these
couples I don't believe your marriage is
valid I don't care you can go on
vacation all the time I see these
couples at they're on these extreme
vacations where they stay in these
little glass igloos in Iceland and they
they go to all these beautiful places I
know you don't love each other I see it
in your eyes you could tell with people
you know that young love when kids
really love each other and they're in
college there's some shitty fare they
don't need anything except a churro and
a ferris wheel the vacations keep
getting more extravagant it's because
you're trying to reignite this flame and
we all see it out there on Instagram we
all know what's happening the most
extravagant vacation you take is going
to be the one where one of you kills the
other one in their sleep I'd see it
we're going and we're gonna go and we're
gonna John camels are gonna go across
the Gobi Desert and then we're gonna
look at the stars and that you just
don't love each other anymore that's all
see these extravagant extravagant
vacations people take go on these
extravagant I want to stay at the summit
of a mountain with my love with my love
because we love each other so much that
we need to be we need every minute of
the vacation to be planned for us and we
need to do a lot of excursions because
if we don't have if we're just sitting
on a beach next to each other we're
gonna have to talk to each other and if
that happens it's gonna go downhill
quite quickly so we need people to get
us out of bed roll us out of bed and put
us on an excursion and we need to go
ziplining immediately because if I have
to look at your face I'm gonna kill you
so we need to go ziplining we need to go
right now
it's got to be a fun adventure no more
peace and quiet we can't handle that
peace and quiets not to move from the
minute we touch down so the minute we
leave it's gotta be chaos controlled
chaos I want to get a massage we got to
go to a spa where we are beaten and
injected with things smacked with
seaweed
we need sand rubs and we need it all
because we can't spend any time with
each other unless we're being pat we
need to be pampered by other people
because if we try to pamper each other
it'll be a problem it'll be a real issue
I see you people on edge too in its
dilemma I see one the Graham I'm not
hating you yeah I'm mad no it'll take me
on one of those yeah I'm mad cuz I'm a
bad person too and I deserve to go to
places that are ridiculous
I want a five-star hotel chain to take
whatever natural beauty that's left on
this planet colonize it and sell it to
me and a little twink
doesn't speak because he's deaf dumb and
blind mute and it's not rape he consents
via Braille okay
8ki consents yes he needs me to open
doors for him and turn on lights if he
leaves me technically he will die
especially where we're going on vacation
we're going to a volcano there's no
arguments with a deaf thumb mute but
he's not that dumb it's not a [ __ ]
I'm not saying I'm having secular time
okay let's strike dumb he's just deaf
and mute but he's very intelligent
he reads Braille books all day he has a
huge penis
and I want to go and stay in an igloo
with him for $2,500 a night in a villa
with a wild local wildlife school what
the [ __ ] going on some poor sloth who
now works for the Four Seasons comes and
gives you your drinks some tortured
elephant has to just just walk up and
this majestic animal has to fill your
face with food he just takes an apple in
his snout and gives it to you that's
what I want I want every piece of this
earth colonized taken and sold back to
me I don't have that kind of money we
get 30,000 [ __ ] Hughes we need more
we need a million Jews so I can go on
vacation in a volcano and maybe the rob
city kills a native shut up I problem
cares the kids you can't just go to a
lake is my point and sit there you can't
just go out to Joshua Tree and look at
the Stars you have to invade a corner of
the country and make it and it has to be
ridiculous your Instagram vacations have
to make me go oh my god I didn't even
know you could do that there hotel room
is on a melting glacier I can't believe
that it's so beautiful well yeah because
of climate change the glaciers melt
we got a room right on one of the
glaciers it's it's really gorgeous
absolutely beautiful you know I just you
know I haven't gone on a vacation in a
long time and that's all people talk
about by the way it's a vacation if I go
out with young professionals they talk
about their vacations cuz their jobs are
all too complex for them to get into
because they're all fake or they're all
inherently evil so they can't really
tell you about yeah well we do you know
think I'm you know it's it's kind of
like a LinkedIn for human traffickers
whatever it's it's a you know it's a
small business it's business-to-business
sales more it's an experimental just
kind of whatever it doesn't matter you
go to brunch for these people just want
to talk about think hey where if you got
if you got a wheel up where have you
gone the great rake up went on one
vacation New Orleans with his mother she
took him three years ago she flew him
first-class and he left her knee went to
a strip club that's how to live a life
that's how to live life traveling is so
overrated I do it every week there's
nothing to learn the earth looks like
[ __ ] stop hiking the earth is dead
people in California their brains are
sunburned they hiked there's no
vegetation it's all been killed people
in these arid desert wastelands it's
just mountain lions and rattlesnakes and
these morons these executives just hiked
through them it's gross there's nothing
to see here
it's all overrated it's my point get to
know yourself be real connect to reality
okay
traveling great okay oh yeah I saw we
went we went and we saw it was oh the
Sun show the Sun shirt was so beautiful
shut up sunsets everywhere
that's everywhere
start traveling to war-torn countries
start traveling to cities that have
collapsed that our sacrifice zones start
traveling to places where you fear for
your safety you want to learn so you're
not learning anything unless your fear
for your safety then you learn
oh you'll learn you want to learn how
the world really works go take a
vacation to Flint Michigan drink some
water
that's a real extreme vacation isn't it
do that I'm aware many people listening
to the show go on vacation and many of
them some of them enjoy the comedy some
of them some of them probably are
offended or they they think I've gone
too far here because I'm suggesting that
instead of going somewhere nice for
honeymoon you go to Assyria where you
might get killed or go to Flint Michigan
at night I understand that now even
though this is kind of a bit I do I
can't describe to you how much I do want
you to do that I do want young
professionals going to Libya I do want
them going to Yemen out you want me to
listen you a brunch that's how you start
a conversation me and John we went to
Yemen last year and so first of all it's
very interesting in Yemen so they're
doing the Saudis are doing a genocide
with a lot of the money and weapons that
we provide them and a lot of the kids in
Yemen are so cute but they're their rib
cages bulge out of their bodies they
look it looks like xylophones remember
used to play xylophones in school and
they have no food and they don't really
have any clean water it's really sad but
there's so much history there's so much
history I just want I want that and I'll
go oh you're really learning you're
really learning we went to Flint
Michigan last year me and cliff we went
to Flint Michigan for our honeymoon and
let me tell you right now
the water was the color of human shed I
said to cliff what kind of resort is SAS
and it wasn't a resort you're just
staying in someone's house like oh my
god this is wild we're learning so much
about different cultures some cultures
apparently don't need clean water it's
wild
so it's so interesting people tell you
how much they learn on vacation we
learned so much when I went on the when
I went on the Impractical Jokers cruise
which was just morbidly obese people on
scooters those people they let them out
of the boat which I called the pen so
they let them out of the pen on the
fourth day because we had docked and
Costa Maya Mexico which is a fake town
that was bought by you know Carnival
Cruise Lines and we think all the people
that lived there they said you can
either work for us who we could just
poison you I guess that was the choices
and they decided well I guess I'll just
sell knickknacks to these fat people and
these fat slobs were walking around this
pretend thing in Mexico and like they
were like there's all these fake booths
selling like traditional Mexican art
which was not you know a traditional
Mexican food it's Mexican chocolate was
good like could die for its traditional
Mexican food it was like Taco Bell and
these fat Americans were walking around
like you're really learning about
another culture now if you left if you
went three minutes outside of that fake
little town which was literally just a
consumerist help if you went three
minutes out of that town there were
people running around without shoes
chasing chickens hoping to strangle them
for dinner people were living in huts
and I went with one of my friends the
great Michelle a great woman and a demon
and she went with us and you need people
like her because otherwise these people
will eat you we got in a taxi that took
us to the beach and the beach you know
and the taxi took us all through these
shantytown and the tax he would not take
his back and Michelle started screaming
y'all take us back right now that she's
like no this is as far as we go home it
sounds like y'all take us back now and
there's nothing like the wrath of a
middle-aged white woman who's never
heard the word no because she'll never
stop she won't stop okay until there's a
diplomatic problem until an embassy
she'll go to an embassy start banging on
the door so the taxi had to take us
around but it was just so funny when you
went out of this little Cruz area you
walked around and you just saw people
without shoes running around and you're
like God you like get me back on that
boat and of course that boat was a
floating toilet but you were still like
just get me back on that boat we had
like sick there was like 60 shafts on
one of the cruise liners at dock 60
chefs there was like one doctor in this
whole town and it was like a witch
doctor you'd go in with a problem and
they would do a dance around you they
were still doing bloodletting with
leeches we pull up with 60 chefs people
just throwing away food you know but
it's a lot to learn just at least own
the vacation I want to go get drunk and
have fun that's what I love my Long
Island friends ago I just want a drink
somewhere warm that's people along I
outside I don't want to go to London I
want to get hammered somewhere warm
Vito I don't want to go to it what's
that Vito doesn't want to go either this
is a fake heart you better go the long
dirt I want to see no that's none of
that I want to go to Greece
the bird plays at the Bhakra see they
want to sit on a beach they want to get
hammered because it looks different from
their backyard this whole thing would
vacate oh these fake people is likely
learn so much on the vacate you're not
going to learn
go and get hammered and I'm fine with
that it's okay forget it stop disguising
the fact you want to learn you know
I will I will accept advertisements from
Cruise Lines I will I will let you know
that I will absolutely I have no problem
with that no problem at all I think
everyone should bring your guns on
vacation I think that would be fun they
should have a gun lovers cruise and
people could just shoot at the Atlantic
Ocean they could just shoot their guns
into the water why not
the fish would get to know they'd be
like oh the gun crews the NRA cruise is
coming they're gonna start firing their
guns into the water do that it's fun why
not vacations I'd love to take a
vacation but I've had enough had enough
of people you know folks I know that I
know that I seem extreme but you know I
want the best for all of you that's all
everything I do here is for the
betterment of you as people that's all
that's what I'm trying to do I'm trying
to give you a life plan okay and I just
think the vacations should just be about
excess go eat go drink go be a pig
you've earned it
you've earned it if you want to go learn
go live somewhere for six months you
know nobody nobody travels I suggest
that's people I go get out of here go to
China my friend's little brothers
sisters get the [ __ ] out of here
they don't want to leave their lawyer
who I want to stay
Koller n-- something could take six
months for a year you're not learning
anything
taking a walking tour okay of Madrid you
went to the Prado and it's down go move
to Spain be a lazy trunk like that old
country is they get it right they just
drink and lay around all day they don't
give a [ __ ] does it matter to them
folks I want to tell you about Monday
comm it's a team management tool that
will improve your office workflow Monday
comm makes it easy to track projects and
stay productive instead of email
spreadsheets random files whiteboards
to-do lists post-it note reminders
Monday comm organizes and tracks
everything in one place the best part of
it it's intuitive it takes no time to
setup it's flexible you can easily
customize it it's easy to stay organized
and find files looking through your
emails to find stuff is a nightmare
especially if you're a boss or CEO you
know most of the people that you employ
you're gonna be brain dead slackers
losers parasites okay you're never going
to expect them to have as much they're
not gonna have skin in the game the way
that you have it okay you're the one
that's inspired divinely by God to
succeed the rest of these people they're
heathens they're walking around just
completely useless
you just need them creates
accountability what's more annoying than
asking someone to do something and never
getting a response are they working on
it do they never get the email how often
our important task getting lost in the
shuffle with Monday comm you can easily
assign tasks to co-workers in track
project the platform is suitable for any
size team for two freelancers working
together to thousands collaborating
across the globe
so check out Monday comm this is
incredible team management tool when did
that calm is so effective it'll put an
end to long boring meetings no more
endless meetings trying to figure out
new tactics for staying organized for
who's gonna be working on what Monday
comm does it all for you Monday comm /
Tim you get a 14-day free trial if you
don't like it folks you parties friends
okay Monday dot-com / Tim you get a
14-day free trial I know from working in
the business world that a lot of people
that you're gonna end up working with
are not going to be able to pass muster
they're not going to put in the time and
the effort that you are they're not
gonna have the energy they're not going
to be inspired they're not gonna be you
know resilient they're gonna have bad
attitudes they're gonna be negative
you're gonna you're gonna really regret
them the sight of them will make you
sick so we need to do is create
accountability so they can't say I lost
that email I never heard about that
meeting what was I supposed to do Monday
comm organizes all this so you can get
back to doing what you do as a boss
making their lives hell
you know if they screw up you go and get
him sit him down go what are you what
are you what do you want to be want to
be a blue-collar guy like your father no
really sock it to him and you can do
that with Monday comm folks you can do
that you can really let them have it as
a boss and that's the funnest part of
being a boss is letting somebody have it
making sure all your Ducks are in a row
and that the error was 100% on them then
bringing them into their office and
really giving it to give them to a good
shut the door sit down take a drink of
coffee and you look at them you know
what the [ __ ] are you what are you are
you a loser or you a winner
you're a winner like Gary Vaynerchuk
says cuz a winner would not have
forgotten that email oh I don't think I
ever got it yeah yeah pull it up Monday
comm you got the email yeah a loser
you're a loser my kid is sick hey shut
your mouth shut up
Monday doc connors it was gonna be a
Monday so there's gonna be somebody you
know you're my party on Sunday drink
your sangria dancing your flats with
your fat ribeye steak size feet but then
once you get into the office on Monday
nobody wants to hear about it nobody
wants to see you sway into a Billy Joel
song they just want to want to connect
with you
you know Monday com Monday dot-com / Jim
14-day free trial if you don't like it
don't use it but you're gonna love it
you're gonna use it okay have I ever
steered you wrong
viral idea I have a disrespected you if
I ever showed up at your house and
stolen money from you know why wouldn't
you trust me I'm not some schmuck I'm a
businessman I have a business I
understand business I'm a leader I'm a
strategist I'm a confidant okay so
Monday calm / Tim Monday calm the emails
are gonna be good don't lose the emails
Monday calm don't lose the meeting
notice dial into the conference call is
everyone on the call damn right Monday
calm how the numbers last month good
they could be better
Monday calm under the day in a cubicle
Monday calm Monday dot-com Monday
dot-com / Tim use this [ __ ] thing
people have said to me uh what do you
think will happen with the Epstein thing
I've said this before I've said it many
times the answer is nothing and I know
that that perplexes some of you because
many of you have not paid attention to
anything ever
and I think that is the issue to live
now and have never paid attention to
anything ever
must be disorienting for many of you
know there is no justice it will not
happen don't look for it it's not going
to happen they're not going to get you
slain Maxwell she's not gonna you know
she's not gonna [ __ ] blow the whistle
they're not gonna haul the Clanton's out
of their house you can believe in the
queue and on and the fairy tales on
reddit and you do whatever you want you
can do whatever you want we are we are
not the protagonist in the novel here
okay
we're on a ride
we're on a ride at Disney World all the
loops hi they're all predetermined to an
extent the ride will and you'll get off
the ride oh I thought we were gonna
[ __ ] something was really gonna
happen there and remember and uh but it
wasn't you've all been on rides and
people like that to get off and they're
like I didn't I thought we were really
[ __ ] but we went around the curve no
that's not it no you're not the one
that's gonna happen to you're not there
you know it's a ride hill hick set it
Hill Hicks had a nice positive vibe I
should take I may start tripping out
again that might be what I need to do to
deal with these people even to even have
a conversation with people now I need to
be on a dose because you've never that's
the thing people never pay detective and
paid attention and they think they're
like surprised look this is surprising
that we're not gonna and the reward is
to not pay attention the reward is to
put your head in the sand that's the
reward that's how you succeed
that's how you win you want to win go to
bed if you want to win close the book X
out the window go to bed the rabbit
holes don't end they just get deeper and
deeper you dig yourself deeper and
deeper in go on vacation go stay in an
igloo in what's left of this ravaged
planet enjoy it protect yourself protect
your kids maybe if you have a gun put it
to good use and blow your head off
but don't expect that this ends like a
movie does this doesn't end we end
eventually the dollar collapses America
doesn't lead the world the criminals run
the country get more brazen they get
pretty
raisin they're gonna get more and more
brazen that coincides with the
population being stupefied the
population gets very dumb they watch
jiggling asses all day they don't they
don't demand answers they go it was
strange how odd they don't the art that
we consume gets dumber he tells us to
question less we don't question anything
anymore
everything's a Marvel movie where
someone's gonna save the day so is a
superhero that's gonna come in and save
the day there's no superheroes they're
not coming okay that's not the way it is
but that's how you're conditioned to
believe that somebody's gonna call it
sis it bado O'Rourke
it's bait oh god maybe it's Bernie Oh
Elizabeth Warren her folks eNOS she's
just got a mow down the
military-industrial complex with her
folks eNOS no no that's not what happens
what happens is you get old what happens
is you get bored what happens is you end
up sitting on a chair drinking wine out
of a burger can come filled with ice
staring into flames and no matter what
anybody says you look at them you shrug
and you go life in the big city and you
ain't nowhere near a [ __ ] city that's
how it ends so embrace it enjoy it
that's what it is out there folks that
maybe find a few like-minded people to
go huh that was weird you know the next
terrorists attacked it you know someone
pulls off by parachuting into the
Superbowl and you know with a nuke
attached to them or something you know
it you know be Donald Trump jr. but
we'll be told not to question him you
know you might want to make a few
buddies you go to the local watering
hole and go that was stress on huh how
strange that was hard but don't expect
anything
to change the art the movies music it's
kind of get worse
maybe not worse he'll just get dumber
it'll be good the effects will be great
the effects would be great cuz we'll
start killing real people soon those
would be snuff films
we'll start killing real people soon in
films so the effects will be great
that'll be really someone's carotid
artery soon it's coming videos will
start coming out of people torturing
children they'll say it's deep fakes
that's that's coming Oh somebody made a
deep fake Bill Clinton and this thirteen
year old this is strange the elite don't
care about you they worship it weird
temples on Islands it's they are they're
out of it folks it's and they've always
been weird they always hang out with
weird scientists there in the
transhumanism they're into all kinds of
[ __ ] that you'll never be into just cut
carbs lower the carbs feel a little
better but you know this is my message
of hope this is my message of hope to
you I find this to be tremendously
uplifting and I know many don't many
don't they don't find it to be uplifting
but I've paid attention that's the thing
I really have paid attention not to
everything and there's people that have
paid a hell of a lot more attention than
I have and they're dead okay they go
bye-bye they're not here to really give
their thoughts they paid real close
attention so do that at your own risk
but that's that's where we're at folks
enjoy it I'm doing a podcast with loaded
Paul tomorrow we're all here
everything's coming the devil is real
and he's the only one who loves you so
sit in that chair grab a Burger King cup
fill it with ice fill it with cheap wine
and drink yourself till you feel warm
and fuzzy
and stare into that fire and if anybody
tries to puncture your bubble with even
the slightest hint of reality kill them
and if you don't want to do that just
smile and they won't know what you mean
just say hey somebody brings up
something you go hey man life in the big
city
and close your eyes and that's it okay
and that's a true true victory in these
times also you know let me get a Casper
mattress people say that they're say
that they're good hopefully they come on
board pretty soon because if there's
anything that we advocated sleeping
Tim Dylan comedy dot-com if you want to
see me live it is more upbeat I am more
upbeat live it's funnier although this
was kind of funny you know to a certain
crew to a certain crowd sure it's funny
I enjoy it
got to do it you love mm-hm all I am is
the guy that's walking around going
bring out your dead that's all I am here
I'm just the modern version of the guy
ringing the bell during the plague and
going bring out your dad that's all
except nobody's got the plague you're
not bringing it you just bring you out
adderall zombies who want to go on
vacation the dead talk bring out your
dad they go I'm going to in gweelok
that's what the dead look like now they
look better than you because you're all
out there going to music festivals and
they're at the gym and they're going to
Anguilla I stayed in igloo bring out
your dead
ed bring them out sit them in seats
I'll entertain them I'll do a nice dance
they won't even feel with a rat bidam
they won't even feel with a rat datum as
always folks stay safe out there love
each other love yourselves and remember
there's a lot of people peddling
negativity but I'm not one of them I
believe in a bright future not only for
this planet with a civilization I
believe the best days are ahead I
believe good things are gonna happen and
by that I believe that an alien race
will destroy us
and it's slave the rest of us and we'll
all start again and that my friends is
best case